nearly everyone remembers mr. Rogers
neighborhood it's a beautiful day but
not everyone knows that this cardigan
clad king of children's TV Fred Rogers
was actually a pioneer who challenged
racial stereotypes and media enter
Francois Clemens Francois Scarborough
Clemens and his role as officer Clemens
made him one of the first recurring
black characters on a children's TV show
when I started there were two three
shows period on television that employed
a black character Francois grew up
during the civil rights movement and
times of great racial tension in the
u.s. so and Fred asked me to be a police
officer Fred are you sure do you know
what policemen represent in the
community where I was raised and then he
started talking about children needing
helpers and the positive influence that
I could have for young children my heart
open as I listened to him he accepted
the role not knowing he would end up
playing officer Clemens for 30 years and
one of his most memorable scenes is also
one of his favorites there are many ways
to say I love you
it's a very big deal for me to be
putting my feet in the water with Fred
during a time of segregation the
symbolism wasn't lost on Francois to say
that he didn't know what he was doing or
that he accidentally stumbled into
integration or talking about racism or
sexism that's not mr. Rogers it was well
planned and well thought out and I think
it was very impactful there are many
ways to say I love you that impact was
felt by many before Francois it was
personal
I was in the studio one day that
particular day he was filming the end of
the show and when he got to the part he
said you make every day a special day
you know how by just your being you and
I swear it was like she's looking right
into my eyes and when the music stopped
I said Fred were you talking to me and
he said yes I have been talking to you
for years but you heard me today